what up anime fans this goes on here and
kid Kai and we're here to talk about
Dragon Ball super episode 42 so kid Kai
initial thoughts um well clearly it's
not as on par with the other ones but
you know I feel personally like it's
just the transition episode and I know
the next three will be a transition
episodes as well but we did get some
interesting information from this
episode I'm going to start things off by
saying it looks like most likely there
will be a giant universe multiverse
tournament yeah they're definitely won't
be I can't see that not happening yeah
for sure and I guess they run out of
like fun day yeah I can't wait to see
the other you got the distortions and
other fighters from the universe's I'm
pumped excited I want to see more
development to the Dragon Ball mythos
and all the other things and it's going
to be interesting to see fact I can't
wait to see the design and like
everything from the superpowers to the
actual designs of the other gods
destruction that's going to be intense
and all the other characters as well
yeah so clearly this episode was kind of
crazy and I'm just being consistent with
like sticking to Dragon Ball super
universal like the rules that have been
established but I think we should just
look at these kind of well maybe filler
episodes as sort of just taken in for
what it is I think we're mostly should
look at the humor which this episode was
considerably like funnier than a lot of
other episodes I think that's the focus
like we shouldn't focus too much on
let's say stuff does make sense like
wire it go 10 and Trunks never aging
right right that I mean that's a bit
ridiculous but you know these we can
call them fillers they don't stray too
far off from what's going on in the main
story arc so you kind of can consider
them iike more considering more filler
but yeah you can kind of consider them
cannon but yeah it's kind of ridiculous
that goes to the trunks have an age and
there's one scene I don't know why it
seems like trunks is a foot and a half
taller and go home which
really weird even like I don't know
where that came from it all go tell ya
so much inconsistency I don't know I was
starting to think that maybe they age
slowly to but Gohan's fine so yeah go on
age is like an Earthling so we'll see
what happens but maybe maybe it depends
on which side you pull your genetics
from so we'll see you know Goku looked
like he was like 10 all the way until
like 18 you know and then he hit that
growth spurt and came back taller so I
don't know there's one more consistency
again it's that power scaling thing I
talked about in one of the earlier
reviews i did was like I don't know how
Goku is fighting on par with buras and
he wasn't even he was in his base form
like he was literally yeah but to be
fair I don't think beerus was going all
out it kind of looked like he was funny
when he took the mask he was but I guess
again I'm late again I just think this
is like mostly just comedy yeah I think
it's heating just to overemphasize oh
man this god of destruction has to put
on like a mascot suit you know how
ironic it is that he's come to this and
I think they're just trying to like /
app size for example bureaus has been
very like overdramatic this whole
episode whatever Goku shows up oh no her
maracas and music oh my God he's like
sweating right so they're kind of
overdoing how how much Beatles cares
about all this stuff because I mean he's
the god of destruction like he went from
being completely cool and mellow to now
freaking out over a yeah that's the
thing about him he is full he destroys
galaxies in the blink of an eye he
doesn't really care about life that's
not his job and then all sudden he cares
about these guys from Planet Earth
they're likea to him it should all be
the same like you know he is possibly
and partially he doesn't care his job is
to destroy things while the kaisers
mental great things so I don't know it
is funny in that Sun generate 100 son
yeah anime fans so I'm thinking like
just look at these episodes as almost
simpsons halloween up sounds like kind
of a there there in between things but
we shouldn't be we shouldn't hold them
to too high of a standard just because I
mean they are mainly slice-of-life
comedic effect and we should accept
for what it is right and I really like
how they're incorporating a lot of stuff
from dragonball that we haven't seen in
a while like Piccolo's can again extend
his arms right are those doing things we
haven't seen you seen dragon ball
character is coming back and we're
seeing the little cats ability to morph
into new right right we're sack for
transform into beerus and we have a man
i can't remember last time softball yeah
to solve and and remember before they
answered like a question about kaioken
like so they're addressing dragon ball
on drying but early Dragon Ball Z and
they're actually you know I like the
fact that they're addressing some of the
loose ends we picked up on although
they're creating new ones but ok let me
if as long as the answer them later on
just because they creative now those me
won't they answer them later definitely
um yeah honestly it is funny I liked the
episode I had definitely had some
comedic of value to it I'm not gonna say
I like it as much as I like them canon
material but it's good nonetheless and
as long as they don't get as long as
they don't extend past three or four
episodes in a row I really don't care I
don't you know like sometimes you get
like right now Naruto just exited out of
filler hell which we like to call and it
was like that for like eight months
which is absolutely disgusting i'm just
being thankful it's it's just four
episodes right right it's for Naruto in
its original series had 82 i believe it
was fillers in a row which is like
eighty two weeks that's more than a year
and a half so let's just hope super
isn't taking any Naruto early day advice
stay away from the fillers another thing
I wanted to kind of talk about is ah
Goku stupidity or why why is he just say
to being stupid and super how can he
fight we he notices menaka is way bigger
says like doesn't doesn't think oh man
is not menaka then he notices that like
he should notice that his arm is falling
off because virus was fighting in the
maracas suit his ears coming off and
goku doesn't know and then even when he
sees the other menaka he's like oh my
god you could turn it to to like boo
like what like
are you I don't but I don't want to
believe it you know cuz like to me Goku
wasn't that stupid you know like when he
destroys fresa inn in Planet Namek like
when he almost destroyed he's you don't
get them that perception is that stupid
but I think it's it's what these
episodes and when nothing's on the line
that they kind of overemphasizes to
better yes that's life in a situation
like he is not he is not listen he I
don't think he's stupid he's definitely
not as smart as balmy as you know she's
a genius and she invents things all the
time but um they're different kinds
intelligent right right and then you
know Vegeta is a brilliant strategist as
well as piccolo Piccolo's supposed to be
super genius because of his namekian
heritage but overall on the thing is is
like they definitely make Goku see more
stupid than he actually is I don't think
he's stupid when he gets serious both
like you said when he's fighting free
zone when he fights cell when he fights
majin buu you can only when he gets
serious he is definitely a on average
intelligence if not maybe slightly we
know he's a combat genius in terms of
fighting in raw talent like he's his IQ
for fighting is unmatched almost if you
will by non gods will say and we said oh
no fuistes a god or whatever the hell he
is um yeah I definitely agree with you
on that point anything else you want to
mention well what do you think going on
from here we're gonna see we saw a
little preview about pan next episode
and like what do you think is that
happen next excited for next step so
yeah it's interesting I definitely want
to see pan introduced that's a character
that was introduced at the end of Dragon
Ball Z but they do skip sometime in the
last episode so it does make sense that
she's introduced now on I'm hoping that
go tanning trunks again they start you
know developing getting bigger and stuff
like that all that'd be nice I really
want like everyone to start getting in
other training again and like the
improving and Goten trunks have big big
potential Gohan has big potential and
hopefully he's been working with piccolo
so I want to see I don't know where the
next arc is necessary going I hope like
use like we said last time that they
skip
or that they leave the multiverse
tournament later so people have times
like strength enough but yeah I
definitely want to see all all of the
sayings at least and pickle to be honest
get in on the next adventure yeah I
won't go on to be there man like i don't
understand he doesn't have to be
fighting i want them to be there as a
character like he was one of the most
popular characters like top three for
sure and then also zach not even part of
it we need to revive that you're putting
stupid characters such as like jock
oldest galactic patroller like nobody
really gave a [ __ ] about and then you
know this is funny but I war and stuff
like that and I really just don't give a
[ __ ] about that like I want to say go
home back like you don't use mess oh man
and then that blue guys coming back next
up so what's his name from treated from
oya Emperor pilaf yeah definitely he's
the one in GT wishes go could to be a
kid like he yeah he for example is is
completely comedic relief and it works
sometimes hitter miss for me but yeah I
am not loving him i knowi don't get too
much of him or at least not being too
much of him it gets annoying like if you
watch the movie it's annoying that
there's like a solid 24 minutes of him I
don't know why he's just such a stupid
character we don't give a [ __ ] about
empower law there's a reason he
disappeared for near from well I don't
even know if he wasn't dragon ball z I
can't remember momentarily like he is
just you know he's so thought or level
it's ridiculous like he's keys he was
like one of the first villains and
Dragon Ball that's how weak sauce he is
you know I they ok they brought a bad
for comedic effect right but like he
consistently bringing him back you're
just beating a dead horse at this point
yeah I'm wondering why are they trying
to make them like you know almost main
characters like I mean I wish he'd stay
in his own kind of work I don't want him
to like now keep going beyond but we'll
see baby maybe it becomes a good thing
who knows and in final thoughts what you
think of the episode you raided the hole
I'll give a sex yeah yeah I think I
think six is
fair fair for us for a filler six isn't
worth it yeah definitely and it had
funny moments but it wasn't consistently
funny we we definitely had funny moments
and we look forward to the next episode
but even more we look forward to three
episodes down and yes getting back to
the kin and material so we'll keep we'll
keep covering this as every episode but
really we can't wait for the non father
material right to start under way but
we'll see how this goes if this gets bad
with in terms of filler will definitely
start talking about other content and
take a break if they continue with
fillers but we'll see we are planning on
doing like special episode reviews like
the father Bardock up special episode I
can't remember exactly what it's called
in the Future Trunks special episode and
maybe a couple of the movies will see we
will post those on the channel maybe
we'll post the next sunday if the
episodes just really that bad instead of
its place so um yeah keep tuned stay
stay on our channel watch our material
we're definitely gonna have a lot of
giant ball z material coming for you
guys and other things we're not just
Dragon Ball Z we're very anime anime up
for ya and I upper were very anime
diverse alright guys thanks for
listening this has been goes on and kid
Kai and we'll see you next week see you
later space cowboys